yeah what welcome to healing SG 1700
that's not an old him I just wanted to
play g6 I couldn't play Queen age five
pick up the porn ruler oh my god I
wanted to play g6 that looks bad oh my
god oh wow let's plan a fire how well it
looks really really awful it's a good
way to lose against someone with this
rating playing silly Mouse lips whoo I'm
probably not lost but looks pretty wrong
I think Buckner at six at least that
would control of 85 so it's not going to
push me five anytime soon yeah with this
problem
yeah is it good to give this check okay
it probably cannot be terrible so let's
do it this is not such a bad position er
it's not well it's not good but oh maybe
I should have actually avoided the check
but okay it was hanging out the Queen on
h5 at exhibition the English it looks
aight Bishop looks bad
free trade would be good something like
that I'm really unsure how to handle the
central structure and I'm thinking about
playing if I there simply chose to block
it out to block the center yeah come on
I'm going to do it so we just put more
pressure here I wonder if Bishop c5 is
actually an idea putting my bishop here
under fire probably yes quite a problem
here this pollution and the night i will
probably recruited okay he forces me to
do it hit bring the night to f7 know
very well played young puts the bishop
over oh not good maybe I need to put the
bishop on f7 a six is hanging out so
while that's a really terrible game I
mean I will certainly put it back a
little bit violent mouth slit but the
position wasn't so bad it was entirely
unintended to to be in the situation but
Queen 86 or Prince if forms
you
yeah i cannot i can play five what did
not play in five against okay night f7
they're pretty mad so i have to really
stage a fantastic come back yes they put
the from this position this is
completely completely completely busted
young ok gif six that's not really a
good line of submit so let's still try
and 5d five would be greater level 85 I
would have some chances but he's on that
a million times can't cancel yes okay if
we trade this I think I'm not unhappy
just gets the night a little bit a
little bit more active no that's good
make sense them it really does make
sense mine either h8 is also fantastic I
can just push cons is the thing without
lady five takes Bishop b4 still doesn't
work really okay i can double and then
take you five mini
I can like take and Bishop before it he
can he can take on the five it just does
not do anything at all it's a fantastic
fantastic piece ready the age 89
[ __ ] to be d5 takes Bishop before age it
doesn't work you can take on c6 just
take on 66 down oh my god it's so simple
and this is the problem also and it is
this like so simple to win everybody is
anybody is going to manage that I cannot
post problem see 129 money get something
going yet if you have to pull some
problems and here I cannot do it ready
okay that helps that helps where does he
want to go there c8 or something let's
prevent that
I mean it still still lost but at least
i'm not getting mated or anything like
that quickly which was possible I think
that it's good could have ended in some
meeting attack might actually have a
square and so unless it's not as
terrible as it was yes h6 or something
maybe you will come around with the book
I guess check check okay I'm getting
something here we do 94 is already
possible okay
[Music]
that was extremely worth it I'm until
I'm extremely lucky game yeah I was a
whole whole disaster at from the from
the opening mouse liver and then then I
mean and it will actually not so bad I
mean f6 isn't it yes they're the easiest
is probably if you check just to take
the polonium I have no compensation
there okay this movie makes sense to
analyze it it's just a mouse club then
the way that is this went I mean I think
this isn't so terrible and not good can
also probably not directly using or
anything but he completely am completely
out let me hear I mean it's not very
entertaining to play for black whip
still champ this is probably also quite
wrong and maybe I should like to bring
this over and then say that okay I've
got all these pieces on the seven train
but they kind of yam do the wall or
something yeah do the walls make the
other guy pay for it that'll be cool
yeah anyway and yeah can you say you
just killed me completely yeah yeah
should play a five I actually thought
that this means the porn but I mean you
know I can't play here and keep this
covered which is still good for why of
course but I'm not losing a bone and
after after this code lost the question
is just host maybe you should have taken
actually that okay it is the total wings
it only gotten a little bit tricky later
when I think roughly here I was getting
some hope because when he takes this I
think that helps me a little bit
and it got it got really difficult for
him actually put this here this is not
easy to win it's equal materials and
porn-wise hi phones each but you have
some kind of fortress character it's not
so easy to win I mean he should win it
so probably very substantially better
but I don't feel this is totally trivial
anymore and when when I am going to
start to to enter here I don't know I
think you probably have to give up one
of the pond and try to enter me look now
I kill that as the end and gives you a
seven or so something something like
that is probably correct just get get
into my camp right if I take here would
be to be certainly did this kind of
thing I didn't calculate but something
like that is probably probably winning
oh yeah you would get to Bishop actor
roughly here look at union that still
looks very good yet from some way okay i
know i don't have to but but nothing to
do i mean i have to play those moves if
they would they do such as the way i
could've taken on you for already check
check check I couldn't take cause of
this ok I flawless possible before tea I
just have to play inside layer I've got
more time now actually I didn't see that
is so that I was down yeah very lucky
win but once in a while have those as
well thanks for watching